the 1995 movie the net is a paranoid
thriller about this oddity called the
Internet our whole world is sitting
there on a computer it's in the computer
Sandra Bullock's character chats with
cyber Bob orders her pizza off Pizza
dotnet and hangs out with Dennis Miller
during that brief window when he was a
feature film actor as an early cyber
thriller the net introduced the Internet
in as importantly a look for the
Internet to a lot of people but those
web pages weren't real someone had to
get those invented graphics on Sandra
Bullock's computer screen my name's Todd
marks I'm the computer video playback
supervisor for feature film television
and commercials I've been doing this for
about 25 years
Todd's work shows the incredible detail
that goes into major motion pictures and
reveals secrets behind the screens
within screens in movies from the net to
Steve Jobs but it also uncovers a key to
how big stories are told Wow a computer
playback supervisor gets the graphics on
the screens in TV shows or movies
sometimes the screens you see in movies
are added after the fact and sometimes
they're prepared beforehand to shoot
along with the seen people like Todd
have to figure out how to display and
make those graphics or well as Todd
explains well the challenges of doing
any production graphics motion graphics
for playback graphics for a film is to
do something that's visually interesting
conveys the message and is plausible
those are those are my three big things
in the comedy anchorman 2 challenges
common to Todd's job are especially
clear the comedy set in the early 1980s
at the dawn of cable we're starting a
24-hour news channel GNN
the global news network that is without
a doubt the dumbest thing I've ever
heard that meant there were tons of old
TVs in the background each of which had
to be period-appropriate
physically and display something
period-appropriate - they filmed a lot
of the footage on their own because the
easiest way to get something that looked
like it was from the 80s was to make it
okay so what's gonna go on this thing
it's gonna go on that screen and what's
happening Will Ferrell is coming into
the studio so we're not on area so
what's on the screens then in this case
Todd had to plan a lot this chart is
typical of how a playback supervisor
would need to plan for a busy shoot it
breaks down the necessary shots Ron
smokes crack on air there's a neatly
ordered cell in the spreadsheet to get
everything necessary for the shot other
documents carry more specifics when Ron
and the team meet their new co-worker
Linda Jackson Todd had a list of exactly
what background elements were necessary
like the three wall TVs that planning
allows big gags to work without a hitch
when idiot weatherman break played by
Steve Carell when in front of a green
screen in green pants it was clear the
scene would work better if Todd and his
team made the effect happen live it
wasn't that tricky but the production
hadn't really planned on doing it live
and we were like no we're doing this
live oh great the result of all that is
in Team America planning meant finding
the perfect tiny LCD screens for Kim
Jong Il's palace the smaller scale
there's little 7 inch screens right
there something that big screens and you
can see me slide to like lean in without
falling into the set even accommodate
the internship which was set at Google
it meant finding the right giant screens
for corporate presentations but these
screens aren't only important details
sometimes they can be a key turning
point for a story with date night and in
that particular scene with mark Waller
he was a high tech security act now you
might not expect date night to include a
technically driven moment it's a very
light 2010 comedy but Todd's work in
this scene is crucial to landing one of
the movies best jokes in it Mark
Wahlberg parodies a trope of
over-the-top action movie computer stuff
it ends up being pretty funny and that
joke required a lot of work so then we
have to create a whole logic to the
thing and figure out kind of a map out
what we want to do one silly gag
required elaborate mock-ups rejected
concepts and designs to perfectly sink
the digitally inserted screen with the
practical side units on the wall you
might not be looking for a coherent user
interface design in date night but see
how they bothered with the color of that
circular control the filmmakers cared
because it was key to making the joke
worth that attention to design was
important in a different way in the
period piece Steve Jobs which was about
design computers and presentation
basically everything someone like Todd
cares about as far as the challenges
there were so many challenges involved
in that project challenges like making
computers from 1984 look new again you
could pull the old Mac's apart and put
this paste on them and leave them out of
the Sun and it would
the plastics or finding the perfect
build of blueberry I max these details
were key to making the movie and the
movies emotions feel real one of the
most touching scenes in the movies when
Steve Jobs connects with his daughter
over a computer the character is
normally distant but he's able to be
more open and warm because of the
software and in the movie they didn't
fake it
that was a Macintosh that and that was a
special one
John art engineer had actually built his
special video card for that was that Kim
yes at the same time and and we had to
load everything off of floppies about
type your name the artwork was created
by our graphic artist on Photoshop so
then we had to figure out how do you get
this Photoshop document back down to a
400 K floppy form which box has said it
was really boo ting off the real
Macintosh software it's crazy you know
there is something that the actor can
act against it's it's much better it's
better for the director it's better for
timing when things are queued and when
people can respond it's better for the
editors because they have something to
edit against versus trying to cut to
something that's not there and it just
makes the whole process smoother even if
there is something that needs to be
changed later and they have to burn it
in later which sometimes happens that
makes it worth the difficulty and the
stress worth doing live instead of after
the fact the gimmick in the net was a
hidden backdoor that basically unlocks
the Internet you click on the little pie
symbol while you're holding this key and
then you get into that which again was
pretty ridiculous
at least it move the story forward
enough and not you didn't pull you out
the idea is implausible by kind of
compelling there is a whole world tucked
in the bottom right of a screen
somewhere hiding in plain view
that's how movies build worlds with
obsessed over details that make it
easier to produce and see emotion
because there aren't any distractions
because the world feels real to see it
you have to take the time to search for
it this picture is when I worked on Star
Trek nemesis and that's a little ship
the plaques that they have on on the
bridge and it has a lot of the names of
people who worked on the movie so I'm in
there